much needed transformation for the
downtown area the city's newest project
Green Vision the Stewart Avenue complete
streets will start its design plan next
year the goal is to widen sidewalks
improve lighting and bus stops as well
as ADD landscaping and trees according
Olson has lived by Las Vegas Boulevard
and Charleston for the past three years
and frequents the downtown area Olson
says the congestion and Driver speeding
makes it dangerous to be on the roads
you know people used to wait three
seconds to beep their horn and now it's
like one second flat you better be ready
to go as an active Runner Olson says
she's seen a lot of close call Accidents
a truck took the corner and like went up
on the curb as I was getting ready to
cross the street and it's a four-lane
Road and it's just so you know it's
great to to make more room and and these
improvements and again encourage more
people to get on their bike and be more
active in an area where 28 of residents
are living below the poverty level the
city hopes to make this space safer and
more accessible the biggest issue that's
the obvious the homelessness there uh
just that the issues with crime and so
on I did witness a lot of crime when I
was there Reynaldo Herrera lived near
Fremont and Maryland Parkway for a few
years it was dilipitated it was just it
needed a lot of attention and it's
awesome to hear that they're moving
towards Stuart now to improve that area
the city hopes to improve the safety of
cyclists and pedestrians by adding in a
corridor wide speed limit reduction near
intersections it's just awesome to see
the city uh giving attention to areas
like that you know hopefully it could
just it could spread throughout North
Vegas
foreign
applied for Federal grant funds to make
it into a complete Street and a complete
Street means that the city will widen
the sidewalks and add more Landscaping
construction is expected to start in
late 2025. reporting live from downtown
Las Vegas Mary Jane valleza 8 News Now